في محطه لغسيل السيارات باحد الاحياء
الشعبيه في تونس العاصمه منذ سنه 15
يقول انه غير معني باثاره موضوع وجود
الافارقه من جنوب الصحراء في البلاد طالما
انه ملتزم بالقانون
علينا ان نقبل بوضعيتنا هنا علينا ان نعمل
فقط حتى نعيش بكرامه يجب ان نلتزم
بالقوانين
وضعيه ليست كغيره من الاف الافارقه الذين
اثار وجودهم في البلاد اشكالا للسلطات
التونسيه حاولنا الاتصال برئيس الجاليات
الافريقيه لكنه اعتذر خوفا من تهديدات قد
تطاله في ظل الحديث عن استهدافهم وترحيلهم
رغم تاكيد السلطات التونسيه ان المساله
تتعلق بتطبيق القانون فقط
طالبنا بتطبيق القانون ولكن ليطمان
الافارقه الموجودون في تونس بصفه قانونيه
على اوضاعهم
وترتبط مساله وجود الاف الافارقه في تونس
بقضيه الهجره حيث امضت الدوله التونسيه
اتفاقيات في الغرض مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
منذ تسعينات القرن الماضي الهدف منها
دائما وهاتي الاتفاقيات هو الحد من وصول
المهاجرين غير النظامين الى بلدان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سواء كان تونسيين او اجانب
منطلقين من تونس وتعمل سلطات التونسيه
مؤخرا على حمايه حدودها البريه والبحريه
للحد من تدفق المهاجرين غير النظاميين
عليها
بين تعقيدات الوضع القانوني والامنيه من
جهه ومساله حقوق الانسان من جهه اخرى يبدو
الحل لوضعيه الافارقه من جنوب الصحراء في
تونس صعبا في ظل ارتباطه بمساله الهجره
غير نظاميه التي تؤرق السلطات في ضفه
البحر الابيض المتوسط وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس